Lucca is the quintessential Filipino
party food it is a party in your mouth
hi my name is Mel and today we'll be
making my mom's lumpia recipe if you've
ever met a Filipino or had a Filipino
friend growing up
chances are you Catholic yeah lumpia is
just this crispy highly addictive finger
food that's filled with some sort of
meat usually pork my grandmother used to
sneak in all sorts of weird things into
her wing via that I have omitted things
like raisins this recipe is my mom's but
I did add ginger and cilantro I'd call
it like the 2018 lufia there's a raging
debate that will never die between my
mom and my aunt over whose lumpia recipe
is better I gotta side with my mom today
we're using lumpia wrappers you could
also use spring roll pastry wrappers my
mom's pro tip is to make sure that you
roll it into the shape of a tobacco
those are her words take a little egg
wash at the tip use that as glue to hold
everything together
now it's fry time if you were my mom you
would bust out your fry daddy plug it in
and deep fry up a bunch of lumpia but
we're gonna use less oil some people
like to cut them in half I personally
like to keep them whole because who's
kidding you're gonna eat the other half
of it and the must have dipping sauce is
a sweet chili sauce that completes the
dish
yep nail that but don't double dip you
gotta go the other side don't go like
that oh yes
[Music]